dunder-mifflin this is Pam Michael
what's wrong okay wait wait wait wait
Michael do you need me to call an
ambulance
okay way to say I thought you said that
you were hurt hey whoa Michael okay Jim
just say again really loudly what
happened you burned your foot on a
foreman mill I enjoy having breakfast in
bed I like waking up to the smell of
bacon sue me and since I don't have a
butler I have to do it myself
so most nights before I go to bed I will
lay six strips of bacon out on my George
Foreman grill then I go to sleep when I
wake up I plug in the grill I go back to
sleep again then I wake up to the smell
of crackling bacon
it is delicious it's good for me it's a
perfect way to start the day today I got
up I stepped onto the grill and a clamp
down on my foot that's it I don't see
what's so hard to believe
excuse me there's a sign at ramsett park
that says do not drink the sprinkler
water so I made some tea with it and now
I have an infection sir sir are are you
are you are you listening to me sir sir
I'm talking to you sir
sir are you aware that there is waste in
your water system hey Jack
the vending machines broke I know I
broke it I needed to speak with you and
I know that was the fastest way to get
you up there you bastard I trusted you
lemon lemon look chipper captain you
have a fun weekend there was a small
fire in my home I lost many photo albums
of treasured memories
I'm devastated you've been avoiding me
lemon how do you do that without turning
around to be perfectly honest the first
couple of people I did that too were not
you but here we are okay Wendy hot and
juicy redhead we'll give this a try when
did hello Wendy this is Kevin's friend
Michael Wendy oh I'm sorry could you put
her on please this is a Wendy's
restaurant okay um could I just have a
frosty and a baked potato please it's a
when I finally clean up the vomit
I found the toe I forgot about the tail
or did we crazy right
the story is awesome indeed thank you
for sharing Jenny Ann was getting a
little chummy when people get too chummy
with me I like to call them by the wrong
name to let them know I don't really
care about them that's a genius move
thank you you're welcome
Lester you wanted something sir
look it's impossible to make you leave
but you do have to sleep and that's an
order sir this is not necessary also
can't sleep without my whale songs Terry
I've seen this before
problems at home so you stay late at the
job but that only makes it worse
everything's great with my wife it's
just my brother-in-law's in town and we
do not get along you thinks I'm a
weakling you
let me get that for you I can do it tiny
Terry does this pickles makes me feel so
small
Oh cares what he thinks no police
sergeant you're a grown man now take
your nap and if I see the lights on in
here I'm gonna be very disappointed at
you hi I'm Michael Scott and for the
next 40 minutes I am going to be your
tour guide through the lives of Phyllis
lapin and Bob Vance one of the great
seemingly impossible love stories of our
time my name is Michael Scott Webster's
dictionary defines wedding as the fusing
of two metals with a hot torch well you
know something I think you guys are two
metals gold medals
oh I didn't think anybody being here I
mean I brought you guys a pizza let me
think going on here join us Pete and I
are having a little college night
oh yeah what see me shotgun this oh god
she means the pizza it's a great picture
sir I hated meet you so I have an
eyewitness in the purse-snatcher case
only problem is the sketch artist is out
sick how do you want me to proceed
figure it out Santiago it's your case
yes I will do that
thank you are you bowing no this is how
I walk
what do you need Quasimodo I got to go
meet Boyle and Peralta is there
something wrong with the captain it
seems like he's in a bad mood I don't
know who can tell you're right captain
tough weekend I went to Barbados with my
husband
we both had out of palm fronds and swam
with the stingrays I've never been
happier so listen Michael your branch
have been doing great lately and your
sales staff is reporting very strong
numbers outperforming last year in fact
and I don't know exactly how to put this
but what are you doing right right what
Utica Albany all the other branches are
struggling but your branch is reporting
strong numbers look you're not our most
traditional guy but clearly something
you are doing is right and I just I need
to get a sense of what that is David
here it is my philosophy is basically
this and this is something that I live
by and I always have and I always well
don't ever for any reason do anything to
anyone for any reason ever no matter
what no matter where or who or who you
are with or or where you are going or or
where you've been ever for any reason
whatsoever
sometimes I'll start a sentence and I
don't even know who's going I just hope
I find it along the way like an improv
conversation an improvisation it's rough
in here is it always like this
I wouldn't know don't like strip clubs
smells like a wet mop in here and I get
the feeling that every one of these
women is running a low-grade fever
you're one of the good ones run wait a
minute
hello beautiful
[Music]
strippers do nothing for me I like a
strong salt-of-the-earth self-possessed
woman at the top of her field your
Steffi Graf's your Sheryl Swoopes is but
I will take a free breakfast buffet
anytime anyplace
is this potpourri or chips cuz I'm much
how to get it the lure is a God he was
the first man to be on the cover of
Fortune and Jet magazine at the same
time of course that was back when jet
was actually about jet over ship that
magazine took a weird turn these are not
chips hi my name is Timmy and I'm lost
[__]
captain I hate to be harsh but I think
that these drills are slightly
unnecessary possibly although you are
the boss and your judgment is impeccable
and I guess what I am trying to say is
thank you I agree with this stuff about
the drills not the spineless ass-kissing
so I think it would help if we knew why
we were doing these drills because I
ordered you to resume the drill Timmy
and do not do or say anything that a
seven-year-old boy would not do or say
feel free to consult the script I've
prepared okay but it's a little stilted
I am feeling trepidation at the prospect
of a parentless existence no kid talks
like that those lines were lifted
verbatim from my boyhood diary
you